what about the off switch
that like big red button in the data
center we don't tell anybody about yeah
I don't use that one I'm a fan my
backpack get in your backpack uh you
think that's possible to have a switch
you think I mean actually more more
seriously more specifically about sort
of rolling out of different systems do
you think it's possible to roll them
unroll them
pull them back in yeah I mean we can
absolutely take a model back off the
internet we can like take
we can turn an API off isn't that
something you worry about like when you
release it and millions of people are
using it and like you realize holy crap
they're using it uh for I don't know
worrying about the like all kinds of
terrible use cases
we do worry about that a lot I mean we
try to figure out
what this much red team and testing
ahead of time as we do
how to avoid a lot of those but
I can't emphasize enough how much the
collective intelligence and creativity
of the world will beat open Ai and all
of the red teamers we can hire so
we put it out but we put it out in a way
we can make changes